[Musique] les
tensions montent à la
frontière israélo-égyptienne si des milliers de
soldats se massent la crainte demeure
que la guerre puisse éclater à tout moment dans
trois jours L'Égypte attaquera
Israël cette ambassade d'Israël comment puis-je diriger
votre appel
ambassadeur d'Israël s'il vous plaît j'ai
informations des
services de renseignement israéliens intéressés Je veux surveiller
chaque mouvement que vous faites découvrir à l'intérieur de la
zone le fils du grand Nasser
infidélités si vous faites quelque chose les gens
doivent faire quelque chose de plus grand
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi aidez-vous Israël parce que des
millions d'innocents le feront  mourir des
deux côtés c'est pourquoi tu ne peux pas me quitter
j'essaie de sauver notre famille
personne tu es connu comme l'ange j'aime
ça
tu dois apprendre à gérer ton acide
ni à sauver Israël
tu veux sauver des vies  de tes
soldats
toi